what's the status of tales of the
walking dead
um and do you uh is it gonna be do you
think eight episodes a season or sixteen
episodes
uh i can say it's definitely not going
to be 16 episodes it'll probably be a
tighter
i mean i know i just don't know i don't
know what not i don't know what i'm
allowed to say
uh but uh it'll be a smaller season
um you know it's it's very much underway
uh
uh you know where uh uh i don't know
what i can say
it's me it's been fun i don't want to
get you in trouble but i want
information you know i don't care look
uh uh
writers rooms being built we're working
on it who cares what are they gonna do
fire me
yeah i wasn't i wasn't really uh worried
about you losing your gig
um is that one of those things though
that you guys envision as because the
the recent spin-off is two is two
seasons and you you know right from the
beginning it's two seasons
for for tails do you guys envision
something like that or is it something
that could continue for a long time
uh i don't we're not really talking
about it uh i i don't know i mean we're
hopeful that it'll last past the first
season there's not any kind of cap on
what we're doing we're just trying to
make the best season possible to begin
with and see how things go from there
i think it's a tremendous opportunity to
explore
you know many different aspects of the
walking dead universe uh
to be able to jump forward and backward
in time and
and also do things that are you know
much different than what we've done in
the walking dead thus far
so uh i think it'll be a really cool
show but uh you know we're we're gonna
see how things go
uh the daryl and carol spinoff series
does it finally have a name i think the
rhyming daryl and carol
is is great uh daryl and carol and carol
and daryl and daryl and carol that's
great like
look there's a theme song right there uh
uh does it need another title
maybe not right so you don't have a
title yet
very astute right um where is that in
the production process do you
uh and another one of those uh do you
envision that as you know the
the walking dead type season where it's
eight and eight uh have you guys had
those conversations
uh i mean those conversations have been
had again i don't know what i'm allowed
to say all i'll say is that uh
you know carol and daryl are are very
much a huge part of the 11th season of
the show
and the 11th season of the show is an
expanded season that is you know much
longer than
past seasons of the show have been uh
and so angela and everybody is hard at
work on that right now and
and uh you know the carol and daryl
spin-off is something that
i think will uh you know ramp up in
production closer to the end of the 11th
season of the show which we are very
much knee-deep in right now
something that i've wondered about is uh
have you guys ever talked about doing
like
a walking dead series in another
language in another part of the globe i
know fear the walking dead
did a little bit of mexico and stuff but
i'm talking about like the walking dead
spain or the walking dead paris you know
something along those lines where it's
a completely different country and
different language
um yeah uh i will answer that question
by looking silently over my coffee cup
oh it's entirely possible
right so this could be something coming
it could be it could be i i don't know i
think
i think that could be actually really
cool i think
i think it will be possible maybe
we'll see